Massimo files here I'm here to present
how we utilize what well technology at
UAB to perform image processing for
clinical application and in my talk it's
image processing for awkward diseases
thanks very much for attending this
presentation of how I the the medical
school I work at the UAB University of
Alabama utilized walk from technology to
perform an image processing of a
clinical data full disclosure
sorry for the PowerPoint first of
everything first timer for me I'm a
mechanical engineer I don't have formal
training computer programming image
processing I just that what I was
working there were so many images
available that I thought to make a job
out of it so just to give you some
context of the images they're going to
see in this presentation what we focus
right now it's trying to get
understanding from the medical images on
the ocular pathologies that are patents
presents and I working off the Maliki
Department so we literally focus on the
human eye the particular you're going to
see images of the section of the
stevepaule the eye when we're you have a
portion of the retina that removes from
the inner of the eye to the brain
through the optic nerve
indeed you'll see the short onh standing
for optical nerve hat that is this area
here that means the inner side of the
hoppy nerve had if we change perspective
then we're going to get more accustomed
on the orientation we're going to see
the image is coming this is the anistar
histology showing where the axon that
they are those are the electric cables
they connect the photoreceptors to the
brain
that's the let's say region of interest
for us because the amount of tissue that
we have sitting here on top it tells us
how much photoreceptors are still
transmitting information visual
information to the brain another
interest is these collagen structures
kilometer cube Rosa and this is an
interesting structure because it has to
separate the high pressure environment
inside the eye to the low pressure of
our environmental site in the brain so
you have a pressure this called
intraocular pressure
this side of the structure in their side
and icpsr quite a pressure on the other
side and that's why a mechanical
engineer is taking care of this problem
because it's basically a mechanical
problem you have this pressure
stretching there I the stretch key
becomes above FISA law physiology the
cell starts to die people get blind and
it's interesting because the white part
of the eye is the sclera it's a very
steep College and it collagenous
structure is actually designed by mother
nature to withstand mechanical loads and
the biomechanics of dead tissue
it actually mobilized the biomechanics
of the laminaria browser that at the end
defines a mundo stretching in the your
retinal action that's just to make it
very brief you can kind of think of a
bridge problem where you have to force
is competing against each other and
eventually they might lead to the
disruption of the little membrane column
in the crib Rosa
so to track pathology we actually have
to track the change in the appearance of
the optic nerve a that means quantifying
the morphology of these images that's
why we start to talk about computation
these an image is called it's coming
from a device that is Oct Solis in
machine optical queenís tomography what
you're seeing right now it would be
basically these are over here scan over
time and you see that this that is
changes are beginning over time indeed
that is the morphology gets shaken just
with the just for the fact that there is
an ocular pulse inside your ID that is
scanning that is made by the fluid there
the blood that is coming to the eye this
deformation that can be quantified in
terms of displacement and strain and
plot against tine and that's the purpose
of my job is to make this quantification
biomechanics and morphology so an
outcome of my t my effort on image
processing by using Mathematica its
performing a fully automated
segmentation of the 3d morphology of the
optinal rat for example this is exactly
water of Tamala G's was utilized to
track how big is the canal opening
meaning how large is the bridge was
there
status of the America browser was the
status of debris of the bridge because
we pressure these will just keep on
falling it up to nerve
meaning disruption of the collagen
structure and this quantification here
it tells us how much leaving action does
still present in the eye so they see
there was the first time they we could
quantify automatically the morphology of
an opening her head and by just
utilizing clinical data and the software
is conceived that he just it doesn't
read the PNG s he reads the outcome of a
machine because for us the speed is
critical that's why also we like for
from technology because for prototyping
we can build the unlimited algorithm in
few weeks like a little bit on the
hundred the hood what we have we have
some compiled function that enhance the
visibility of the of the layer of the
tissues that they are not easily
perceivable by the human eye some image
stretching but that quite easily we move
to make the image more complicated in
actually is for example by utilizing a
simple tweak of building an image with a
an interleaving of different information
I actually get an image that has the
narrative light intensity plus for
example the standard deviation of the
light intensity distribution just
embedded in one image 3d volume that's
convenient because then I have kind of
an enhanced image that I can process by
using a clustering approach a fantastic
tool that you find in the Wolfram
language is the image silence filter
that it basically what he does he tries
to understand how the light intensity is
contextualized in in each area of
interest that that your you care to
analyze so thanks to that image
processing we start to separate the
different layers of the of the ocular
Anatomy based on the how the East ogram
both the light intensity contrast
changes across the 3d volume so first up
is the
with some constipation then utilized
here frangie vessel nel filter that it's
a low-level operation and actually am
very thankful to marco so the image
processing for providing access to these
imaging analysis tool because you
breathe the computation time from five
minutes to thirty seconds and for us
it's life the outcome of that analysis
is giving the position of this membrane
structure that because the the Ferengi
vessel filter it analyzes the egg and
back again values and eigen vector of
the 3d volume so because we have a sharp
change in intensity in this direction
then I can locate the position of this
morphological anatomy that is called
Brooks membrane that separates the layer
of the photoreceptor to the kuru
capillary area that's actually I'm not
sure you can see the mouse know that it
would be over here that it's all the
area where the vasculature it's coming
into the eye to provide the feeding all
the photoreceptors are standing right
here by using a derivative filter then
down there we can precisely locate that
that that the region then smart use of
region between our eyes with a very
simple seeding it actually expands all
this area where the black region is
where these on information that allows
us to actually get the anatomy of the
retinal nerve fiber layer that assay
that it tells us how much actions are
moving from the photoreceptor to the
brain so you start to get a feeling of
how we slowly segment that the 3d
Anatomy by using a classification we
split further the light intensity and
unless suspended they all talk about how
we get the morphology dynamically blows
at the end we obtained a quantitative
analysis
in 3d automated of a no CT scan another
way that I used the image processing
with the Wolfram technology it was to
study an interesting problem that
astronauts experience when they are
exposed to long term low growl low
gravity living if you do a web search by
saying visual impairment in astronauts
indeed you see that there are some new
studies that they are defining it
they're trying to understand why
astronauts if this leaving the space
station for too long they start to have
visual impairments it seems that for
what we are understanding this project
that is funded by NASA I do some image
processing for that and because we
actually have an Oct built by a double
engineering ship to the International
Space Station the astronauts they get
periodically some scans that the guest
ship over here and we can do the
quantification and see what's going on
in their eyes
well there is some understanding it
seems that there is all this re over
here the colleague capillary region has
gained all the vasculature that is
beneath the layer of the photoreceptor
that is getting swelling because of the
change of gravity there is more food
that is driven into their eye or because
that region is getting further then the
that the retina is moving away from the
obstacle focus plane so the astronauts
they start to experience and blindness
so the key was developing a logarithm
that automatically will quantify the 3d
anatomy of those vessels they feed the
photoreceptor how we did it quite a bit
of processing by using some of the
mathematical image processing tools
there will be the raw scan it would look
like here the first point is that there
is not really an orientation for
astronauts were in the space so the
images they can come when you're ready
tilt and because you don't want to spend
computational time by processing a lot
of a big image that that's a lot of
black first thing you want to do is to
get that image straight in line so first
operation
we perform a morphological penalization
unfortunately I have the mouse that it
just takes roughly that it localized it
is bright spot in the 3d volume with
that use the heat miss transform that is
going to look of where the pixels are
changing quickly from black to white and
that gives us an outline of what the
Brooks remember in the white membrane 3d
membrane is going to be located amazing
think about that's one of the thing I
love about Mathematica that you just ask
okay how about you tell me over here
what's going to be the orientation of
that 3d structure so because it's just a
series of pixel in the 3d space
Mathematica is going to try to catch the
orientation of this option with this
orientation information you say okay
rotated image from that angle and just
put it straight so we get a volume
straight you know orientation is convene
at that point we can crop it so we
process less pixel we go faster in the
computation
what are see the components is gonna
fill in this area so I can easily build
a region of interest that is the area
that where I want to make the important
computation with some use of non-local
milk means filter that are edge
preserving a filter that gets rid of
noise that doesn't make sense in the
context of the correlation kernel that
you're using to analyze each voxel of
the 3d object you can move from this
kind of low process image to this high
process image where you start to see the
localization of the the the colloidal
structure all the black dots indeed they
are blood because of the Oct there's a
laser based imaging technique the blood
observe the laser doesn't go back in the
camera so it appears like black so all
the black means blood and but because of
their vessel they usually have a pretty
well-defined shape in the 3d space so
what we want is to segment deuce
vessel and understand what's the spatial
distribution so we can quantify and see
if they're changing over time by using a
binary binary zatia approach with with
the automatic treasure analysis there's
a nice thing also that we don't have to
choose manual threshold the wise is
going to be a pressure dependent based
on a logic the cutoff values that are
medically chosen so we start to see how
we can localize everything that is not
corroded vessels and from that by using
clustering approach we start to separate
the different areas where the best of
the stash should show up in with their
own labels so basically these are over
here this object over here they're
basically telling us that deuce they
look differently from the context
because we know what college and all
these all that for everything there
falls in there in there in there in the
mask is not it's it's corrado vessels so
few more steps are computation what we
end up with eat something like this
where you have to transfer on the left
and the right you have to transfer cut
off planes that go in this direction so
to give you the perspective of the 3d
structure of the vessel and you have a
little zoom on the right of anything
it's neck cross a the middle plot is
telling us how in that transverse plane
how big the vessel are meaning that
because we have the L envelope we can
actually compute the volume of the blood
inside that envelope and we can color
code it and plot it so we know that we
can reconstruct not only the 3d
morphology but we also quantify how much
blood it's sitting in that vessel and
that's the key concept of the studies
like let's count how big the corridor
vessel bigger are getting over time and
try to understand if this is a constant
a consistent factor for the the
astronauts if we got back to their
promote the bridge and the structures
changing over time then we becomes the
promise that we need to not only image
the laminaria Broza that mesh like
structure we also have to quantify to
quantify that we have to segment it
there for example I'm proposing here no
CT image of the alarm in and a transfer
view they would me that the optic nerve
will be here it will go to the brain and
the original image will look something
like this and actually this is one of
the top quality images you can acquire
with an Oct what you do you do Fourier
analysis straight to the 3d image value
this term is anything you just get there
the mathematical call applied to the
object and you get rid of all the high
frequency noise from that you can use at
the convolution filter to sharpen up the
image but doing these little steps you
end up being by doing image stretch of
the Instagram you start to move to see
with high-definition the collagen
structure in the lamina it's quite
impressive because we started with this
kind of image and after a few steps we
have this kind of image so with that we
still don't have a binary volume that's
at the end what we want for our full 3d
segmentation so by using few more
strategies like rich filtered it means
the analysis of the main curvature of
the 3d volume first taken value of the
structure tensor we start actually to
see to to have a metric of what's the
spatial distribution of those bundle of
collagen so thanks to that indeed we
start to have a more binary like what
just white or black definition of the
morphology of the lamina but there just
are a free initial guess and that's kind
of important we have just initial gases
because you don't want to have just a
couple of operation straight through
there are volume because if you means of
you have some
always mess up one or two threshold then
you're done so you want to have a slow
approach where you refine more and more
your computations you can rely more on
that because you have more backups let's
say that with a bananas Asian approach
should we start to have a metric of the
collagen structure but the nice thing
that we can do we just call the
component measurements function and we
asked to compute the width of the single
elements thanks to that that that gives
an idea how many pixel on average those
collagen beams are then because of that
then we can actually build a Gaussian a
filter an analysis of the curvature of
the intensity light that they actually
will give us the 3d structure of the
collagen in a more you know in a more
precise manner because we start actually
to know how big we expect to have this
colored instruction and we have to
account for the fact that the
variability across the species
individuals can be quite high so by
building some custom routines that just
speed up a couple of processes like for
example parallelization of the rich
filter right now it's not available if
you do that you have a big machine that
you can do this computation in about ten
minutes if we keep on proceeding with an
attempt to by analyzing the image at
some point you end up with the full 3d
structure of the college instruct all
the collagen being like the one you can
see in your the right plot and I things
start to be to get fun because because
we have a nice we have a binary volume
that tells us how this collagen
structure they are localized in space
then what we can try to do is using a
skeletonization' approach unfortunately
right now Mathematica has an often a 3d
skeletonization approach so we borrow
one from MATLAB but that's the great
thing about Mathematica you might need
something that is sitting somewhere
somewhere else so you can call it so
make a call on MATLAB that has a custom
3d skeletonization approach what you end
up with
it's actually a definition of points
that connects different joints of
collagen beings coming together meaning
that the collagen structure is actually
a network and we can identify the points
where collagen can come together and if
we can do that we can the truck over
time how this network is changing in 3d
and the nice thing is that we have a
tight quantification of the morphology
in a very accurate fashion and because
everything then transform in a 3d graph
then we can zoom in some specific
location and make any computation we
want that is a right now allowed with
the Wolfram language on how this
connectivity of the collagen bangles
it's it's together it's quite
fascinating you can until you actually
travel in the 3d college and networks
and you have a virtual tour of your
laminate we browse that it's an
essential part of your eye and this is
just all possible because in Mathematica
you can grab a 3d volume and
transforming in a graph unfortunately
for the 3d run a doesn't work for this
colonization approach but it's a promise
gonna be solved quite soon and few more
minutes and I'm done that shows a few
more just few more example of how we
perform a high-level company for example
we have access at the UAB to the lab
American Center where we have brain dead
organ donors so people that they are
brain that the body eats they're
actually that but the body is still
fully functioning because they are
preserved to living condition mimic
living condition so that you can
preserve the organ freshness thanks to
that we can perform some imaging
protocols that they are not FDA approved
or not know clinically feasible like
sticking again stick and sticking a
needle in the eye but thanks to that we
can actually test with high precision
how the morphology di changes because of
the changes of the intraocular pressure
that we enforce that we couldn't do in a
human eye or changes of ICP integral
and we look how how the biomechanics of
the entire I it's it's modulated by
these two forces it's something that you
cannot perform anywhere else again we go
back in the analysis we do the comparing
two volumes one with the low pressure
when high pressure they're going to look
a little bit affirmed by using digital
volume correlation approaches we track
the 3d displacements of each point from
the displacement we compute the
mechanical strain then we can plot
against each region of the eye and we
know what's going to be the mechanical
response of each loading condition of
that particular eye in 3d and thanks to
that we can actually not only compute
the mechanical deformation we can
actually look at the 3d structure of the
of the vessel network in the eye and we
can superimpose the 3d mechanical
deformations and so by doing that we can
actually analyze how the mechanical
strain affects the compression of the
blood perfusion in the retina or the
entire eye and we also by using the 3d T
skeletonization approach we can actually
we actually tell that if we are
compression in this area here because
this area is connected with this portion
we might expect some drop in profusion
in the region that is far away from
other computation this is quite amazing
because because there is nothing out
there in the clinic that makes this kind
of quantification and that's really the
future for us because for the after at
least for the ophthalmology field
because we want to have numbers at touch
at the particular case of the eye of the
person is coming in the clinic you don't
just want to have a doctor is taking a
view of the a year fundus you you will
actually want number not just for the
sake of lorry number it's just you can
track progression how the person is
performing that in that moment and how
it's going to change over time
and I believe I'm out of time but the
title of the link was how do we move
that to the clinic well the point is
that a physician I work with this
physician there all day all the time
they don't take the time to log into
your computer and make any computation
and open well from language you don't
care about it then I think about
warfarin cloud is that everything is
going to be available on a web browser
so we are trying to translate these
high-level computation to something very
simple where an MD you can easily log in
in a web browser put some data get a
report even better like Stephen Wolfram
say yesterday if we have a search tool
that searchable database you may have a
just a voice recorder and Wolfram is
listening is going to peg put search
tags grasp what you want inquire your
database and get the results and that's
really the future of of the for the way
I see it of the healthcare in general
because it's all about cost
it is not about perspective what do you
think on what I think it's about time we
have to do computation fast in an easy
way for people that understand nothing
about coding those are the fifth the
physicians so and so we have to make
that available and this is a very simple
example something of the few weeks ago
for one of the labs we collaborate with
is a genetic company because many time
some people have very weird disease so
we did a genetic test we shipped to
their produce lab they do the analysis
of the DNA get the snip snip usually if
there is variation genetic variation to
snip they have an ID so the slab wanted
an easy way to understand was the
potential phenotype associated to the
genotype genotyping means something
really weird is so is in your DNA
phenotype is the clinical manifestation
of that so with the warfarin cow this is
a very very easy but oh I just noticed
that you are not seeing any of this I
guess I'm not going to be able to show
on the screen what I see over here
anyway with the well Frank are we we
hope we can we can bring all these
however computation to to the physician
and so that's my job and I'm very
thankful to also work with a signal for
all from in that effort thank you so
much
[Applause]